so this newsmax panel absolutely lost
their freaking minds when some high
school students said
allah instead of god in the pledge of
allegiance
let's put aside that allah is just god
in arabic and that
correct me if i'm wrong but under islam
allah is explicitly the same god as the
christian and jewish god
as well and let's put aside that
multiculturalism and the freedom of
religion is about as american as it gets
but let's focus on the law itself for 80
years under the first amendment you
cannot make
flag salutes in the pledge of allegiance
compulsory and you can't make high
school students do it
especially the way that you want them to
do it and perhaps one of the greatest
quotes from a supreme court case ever
reads
if there's any fixed star in our
constitutional constellation it is that
no official high or petty can prescribe
what shall be orthodox in politics
nationalism religion or other matters of
opinion or
force citizens to confess by word or act
their faith
therein i think it's pretty cool if not
exceptionally american that this high
school student
felt comfortable riffing on the pledge
of allegiance